hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
our coverage of the match future vs
Nakamura
well basically starting it since this is
the first game we were showing and this
is game 3 from there match now in game 1
the game was abrupted Fallujah lost
I believe Internet connectivity and the
problem is he lost the connection to the
website at the moment where he was
better it was it was an end game and he
was definitely better although both of
them were very low on time so if the
game continued who knows how it would
have played out the problem is they
adjourned the game and then it went for
like an hour without resuming it and
then they agreed that they will not be
continuing it that that game will be
proclaimed the draw now that's a pretty
big issue since it was a Fallujah with
the white pieces and he only got a draw
so he had to continue to match that way
but it would also kind of be unfair if
they continued it after an hour because
a player of obviously there's a strength
he doesn't have to check the position or
anything he can just play it out in his
head and if they resume the position
even with those 30 seconds on the clock
of course however as I would have won
that game easily and the day decided so
game 1 is a draw and in game 2 there was
a it was a completely drawn endgame but
Nakamura was able to trick a larissa and
how it is a blundered so now Nakamura is
leading by by one point and Fallujah now
again has the white pieces and he needs
a win to get back into the match and
it's quite quite a game so without
further ado let's check it out
we have d4 by a Fallujah Knight of 6 c4
we have east 6 Knight to f3 and d5 so
the Queens gambit declined is on the
board and alga Reza decides to play at
the exact same line Magnus used against
Nakamura that in both of their games
with the white pieces so Knight c3
Bishop to e7 and Bishop to f4 now like
Magnus developing it to f4 we have
castles and now III we have Knight B to
d7 and now this anti positional c5 which
we already discussed during the course
in Nakamura game so c6
before challenging that would be six we
have a ch3 and now b6 so everything
continues exactly the same like in the
game Carlsen versus Nakamura a5 a3 and
h6 now and the Bishop to d3 just
developing that and you know that we
mentioned that Nakamura already had this
position against Apollo only Nakamura
with the white pieces and then in that
weird game where Nakamura was stuck with
the white square bishop for the rest of
the game he played Bishop to b7 but then
in the other game that they tended in a
row against Magnus he went for Bishop a6
which he goes against again here he
doesn't want to try out the bishop to b7
line against ali reza we have castles
and now Queen to c8 just defending that
bishop and also once the trader is over
preparing Queen to b7
we have rook to e1 and this is a new
move in the position this exact same
position has been reached many times
initially we had it against Levon
Aronian being headed against sarkeesian
and Nakamura had it we already mentioned
against the polyp and the known moves
here our rook to be one Queen the c2 and
Quinta e - but here like I said rook to
e1 is a new move so already as of move
13 we have a completely new game so
Nakamura continues as usually would
Bishop captures we have Queen captures
and now Queen to b7 just developing the
Queen connecting rooks and it's
important that the sees a c6 pawn is
nicely protected since now you don't
have the option of going e for you you
can't go if or but you don't really gain
anything after all the trades captures
captures captures you can exchange here
once and then just Knight f6 and blacks
position is excellent the c6 pawn is
nicely guarded so instead holidays that
goes back Luke the b1 and now it's a
question what exactly this rook that you
want move achieved but I'm sure they
have the reasons you know there this is
I believe a thoroughly analyzed but ok 8
characters we have 8 captures and now
rook F the c8 by Nakamura we have night
the b2 and now a trader Brooks wrote
characters wrote characters and now rook
the a8 we have looked the b1 again we
are gonna see everything traded off
along the a file like in the game Casa
Nakamura and now this maneuver better b8
followed by Bishop
see seven that was also used in in that
game that is supposed to trade off white
strong dark square bishop so recaptures
we have Queen captures now it's gonna be
a bit difficult to get the bishop to c7
since the queen is on a 8 and now Queen
to a 2 again offering a queen trade
Queen to b7 and now Queen to a4 I just
put a putting pressure on that c6 pawn
and b5 now we have Queen back to a3 in
the now Knights the e8 with E for
finally striking in the center D
captures we have Knight seek actress on
e4 and now Knight d2 f6 offering a trade
here but Knight to d6 we have captures
and here ali reza decides not to capture
with the bishop but Arara with the pawn
because he plans to bring his other
night over to c5 and he's either gonna
have a monster night here on c5 that
will support d7 or a once black trades
you will fix your bone structure so here
Knight to d5 challenging the bishop
bishop just goes back to g3 we have
Bishop to b6 attacking the pawn here
none might be three defending it
preparing the night the c5 move with f6
now preparing to block off at some point
this dark squared Bishop would be five
but Knights the c5 and now it's a
problem not to not to capture on c5 for
example if Queen to c8 you just push d7
you open up this Bishop is diagonal
Queen to d8 and now Queen to a6 is
extremely strong and now you are
basically forcing black the trade the
problem is a white that doesn't
recapture right away because you have
Queen captures here now with ideas of
Queen here so after Bishop captures on
before you can even go Queen captures
and e6 with check first it's taking
effect now you pick up the night and of
course white is completely winning so
instead after night to c5 of course
nakamora captricity and nowadays affixes
his pawn structure the end result being
this protected passed pawn on d6 which
is which is a pretty a pretty incredible
pawn so ii 5 by Nakamura closes up this
dark square bishop and now f3
fuchsia will shift it back into the game
this way we have King to f7 and now
Bishop the e1 we have Knight to f4 now
putting pressure
on the ponds here and the Queen to a to
check we have night back to e6 and I'll
finally Bishop the d2 getting the bishop
back into the game Queen d7 and now h4
so here at Nakamura this position isn't
all that impressive he just has to wait
and see what Alireza will do and since
Nakamura is leading the match of course
he would not mind the draw here with the
black pieces with h5 not allowing g4 so
Bishop to e3 and now King back to g8 we
have Queen to c2 and now comes a knife
to f8 not allowing the Queen to
infiltrate we have Queen to e4 Fallujah
nicely centralizes his queen also
prevents f5 since the epon is under
attack and also puts pressure on c6 so
quite the Queen move we have Queen the
c8 by Nakamura and here g4 with FH
captain g4 f captain g4 and now Queen to
a6 Nakamura is without an active plan
here so he will try to try to infiltrate
with with the Queen this way so g5 but a
for the moment still keeping around the
c64 so g5 and now King to f7 we have G
captors and f6g captures on f6 and now
not pushing right away even though it is
possible first Bishop to f2 so you can
hide a king behind the bishop so you
don't have to worry about all the chicks
Queen back the b7 by Nakamura and now
finally you start pushing h5 by Alireza
we have Queen to d7 and now King to h2
we have King to g7 and now Bishop to e3
preparing to support h6 Queen the c8
nakamura still waits to see what
Fallujah will do we have h sex with
check King h8 and now King to g3 also
the King joins the action we have Queen
to d7 Nakamura forced to repeat and the
King to g2 Alireza again not not sure
what the plan is Quinta c8 and King to H
do we have Queen back the d7 by Nakamura
and King to g3 and Queen to c8 and
Nakamura very happy with a draw here but
Queen to g4 now our res offers a Queen
trade as his he did improve it the
position of his King as much as possible
so Queen b7 of course Nakamura declines
now when F
going after the pawn here so Queen f7
defending and now again Bishop back to
f2 we have Knight to d7 now again
guarding the pawn here not allowing the
Queen to infiltrate with Queen to c8 and
here the position is winning for wife
however it's easier said than done
because black really has a very nice
fortress here and it's it's it's well
it's to put it best unclear how to
proceed with white I will just show it
because it's not something you would you
would think of right away point is you
should March your king all the way here
to prevent any checks with the Queen and
then you will be able to write the
pressure the the Queen side with moves
like Quinta if we're going after the
pond and such the point is you play
Bishop to e3 force black to make a move
now that black moves a let's say Knight
to a fate now you go Bishop g5 you go
after this pawn
once the knight defends it now you start
the King March over to the Queen side
but now you have to suffer a few checks
King e1 Queen e1 check you're gonna go
king e2 and after another check you will
block with the bishop again keeping the
target here on on the 7 Queen back to f7
and now Queen to f3
now putting pressure on the pawn here
Knights to be eight defending it and now
again Queen to a5 with Queen to c8 being
the threat so nice to d7 once again and
now again you waste a move with King t1
and now black has to make a move whether
you will move the knight and allow
Quincy eight or you will move the Queen
for example Queen to e8 then you get
Queen to f3 again putting there so
pressure on f6 but also here and now
there really is no way you can't move
the knight otherwise you lose this point
so you have to go for e4 and then
finally after the Queen moves you will
have won this diagonal to use for your
bishop and this is how you how you make
progress but as both of them are really
long time this is this would be too much
to ask for anyone to figure out so ali
reza went quinta efore he went for the
pawn and nakamura defended we have sorry
we have f5 going after the Queen and now
it could be dangerous to grab the pawn
because here Queen g6 check and
once you go to the H file you're gonna
lose this pawn with check and not with
these two points marching forward with
the knight and the Queen here it's going
to be very dangerous so instead we have
Queen to h4 by ali reza and now Knight
f6 by nakamura we have king to h3 now
King h7 and Bishop the g3 now going
after the pawn but f4 by Nakamura and
all of a sudden it's Nakamura who's on
the attack Bishop to F - and now queen
the east sex with check King G - and now
Queen to f5 so slowly but surely
infiltrating we have king h2 and now
King to g6
even we have Queen h3 offering a queen
trade and now Nakamura finally trades we
have queen captured skin characters and
King actress on h6 leaving him being up
upon however we have Bishop to h4 and
now Knight to d7 you still have to be
very careful with this Knight you don't
want to allow the sponsor to start
marching forward King g4 and now King to
g6 with Bishop to g5 and now here
Nakamura has to make a move and he
decides to give up upon to improve the
activity of asking like I said he is
leading the match so even a draw is is
great for him here so of course you
cannot capture now because King capture
so Bishop to h4 and now just King to f7
we have King captures an f3 and now King
the e6 in here it's pretty much
impossible for white to make any
progress here or black for that matter
so we have King Teti 4 and now comes
Knight to b8 and here interestingly any
move algorithm makes is a draw there's
no way to push for something or even
blunt or something unless the sorry
except the move that a leader is a
played here ali reza for some reason
played Bishop to e7 and here
nakamura just played knights to a6 and
there's no way to defend the b4 pawn
which is extremely weird why why would
you do something like this
but obviously Alireza was well probably
not very happy with himself after he
lost was not lost but he was the thread
of the game and then it was just
Nakamura
who was pushing and now even blunders
upon so Russia back to g5n Nakamura just
grabs at night capture son before Bishop
to e3 in mountain Knight to d5 so here
okay you're down upon but perhaps you
can still hold this Bishop to d2 you
cannot trade pieces that's out of the
question
Knight f6 check King b3 and now King
makes progress King to d5
we have Bishop to e3 and now King back
to e6 Bishop to b2 in the now Knight to
d7 so now now you will again bring your
king to d5 Russia back to e3 ballot is
our King d5 and now Bishop to f2 and of
course you cannot capture if you if you
capture then you just lose the game
because these seven just wins there's no
way to stop promotion so b4 by Nakamura
and now worship the g1 now it's Alireza
who has to wait for Nakamura to decide
what to do efore with check King to see
- and then now King to c4 we have King
Tubby - but now tonight's the 'if I've
again you can you could never really
capture here because like I said if if
the bishop and I come off the board b7
just wins Bishop back to F - and now
Knight to d7 with Bishop to g1 and now
b3 even Bishop back to f2 and now King
to b3 offering this point now to start
pushing the e pawn so King captures and
now III we have Bishop the e1 and now
finally Knight captures here now you can
capture as I then I can always win the
pawn back so King before and now comes
Knight to d7 and here ali reza
probably could have played a better move
king the a5 was the move by a leader as
a king the b3 kind of keeps the king and
bit bay here but okay he went King to a5
and now King c4 by Nakamura we have
Bishop to g3 and now come scheme to b3
cutting off the White King as you can
see so Kings to a6 and now c5 now he
starts pushing this spawn we have King
to be 5 but now see for King to c6 in
here knock more just play Knight to f8
and it was in his position that our eyes
of Arusha resigned
game on move 93 as there is nothing more
to be done here once you push the pawn
and Nakamura will just grab it and after
keen capture she's just placed c3 and
that's it there is no stopping promotion
so really really incredible stuff and
the really tough break for ali reza who
had to do game 1 due to a connectivity
loss in Game one in a in a winning
position in winning endgame then
blundered in in a completely drawn
endgame in in game 2 and then again here
blundered in a completely drawn well he
was much better the entire game and then
blundered in a completely drawn in game
just giving up a beep-beep on like that
and of course now Nakamura has already
won the match so we are continuing with
game 4 and we're just gonna quickly show
game 4 because this is one of the
quickest games you've ever seen so here
after efore but I will just have to I
would just have to give me a give me a
second here I'm just gonna have to
switch positions let me just do some
sorcery here okay there we go
yeah that's it so he car now with white
ali reza with black and on he carves
efore ali reza went for d5 he went for
the Scandinavian now the match is
already lost so at least why not have
some fun so he captures Queen cactus
Knight c3 and after this before I was
very surprised when I saw Nakamura
playing this before mu since I use it in
bullet and blitz so you just give up a
pawn to get a nice SME open file for
your rook Queen back to be 6 and now d4
and ok Queen back to d8 algorithm very
happy and Nakamura continues development
Bishop c4 Knight f6 and now Knight to f3
we have e 6 and now Nakamura just
castles Alireza
also prepares the castle 95 and now just
castles the safety
rook to e1 and c5 now and here is where
the fun starts Nakamura pushes d5e
captures and d5 Knight captures and here
and Nakamura desert just plays Bishop to
e6 and now feel free to pause the video
and win the game for Nakamura while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations unsporting that there
is a double attack on the bishop here on
e7 and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's either Bishop captures on a7 or
Knight captures on f7 which nakamora
played and it's a way cooler so it's
basically the same combination but it's
cooler to start with Knight captors on
f7 and it was in this position that
algorithm game so why did you resign
well he resigned because there is
nothing more to be done here problem is
whatever you well your queen is
obviously hanging so you have to do
something about that problem is if you
capture with the bishop it's it's no
good just Knight captures here with
check and after King moves and now you
pick up the Queen Queen captures and the
rook captures and you pick up the bishop
and at the end of the line you are just
up a full piece so capturing with the
bishop is a no-go if you capture with
the rook it's not much better just
Knight captures with Czech Queen
captures because now your queen is
hanging so Queen captures on e7 and rook
captures on e6 the queen is under attack
and once the Queen moves you just force
it back and it's completely lost doesn't
really matter what you play here you
lose the Queen this is still pinned
complete complete madness and lastly but
not leastly after Knight captures and f7
you could also capture with the King but
then it's the greatest rook captures on
e6
of course offering King captures but
that's no way to play chess just to
going in front of the bishop so here
let's say Knight the c6 you continue
development or play anything doesn't
really matter because the bishop is also
hanging and you can't simply defend
everything so Knight to c6 you can try
to defend the bishop but now rook
captures on f6 a Czech Bishop captures
Enda now of course Queen to h5 check we
just we just runs in tomato eater g6 and
then Knight captures on f6 opens up a
discovery or you move the King and it's
not much better just a double check here
from the bishop and the knight and after
you move just Queen to h7 will be
checkmate so although a lot of lines are
possible here after Knight captures an
f7 if you just resign the game
and congratulations also if you figured
out that this is the position from the
thumbnail so yeah those are the games I
do hope you enjoyed them like again I
decided to squeeze both of them into one
video since this is one is just too
short I mean 14 moves it's pretty crazy
but I really enjoyed the Nakamura
playing before here after Queen a5 I
always play this in blitz and bullet
because most of the times of course the
player would the black pieces will be
expecting something like night or night
of three or maybe d4 or g3 but he will
not be expecting this and he might be he
might pre move Knight of 6 and you will
just win a queen easy happens like maybe
two maybe three out of ten times but you
know those are those are some easy easy
points but yeah now after this he
resigned and Nakamura wins the wins the
match with the incredible three and a
half to half which is I think the first
one so far with such a large margin yeah
those are the games I do hope you
enjoyed them I would like to thank
Patrick dance you dr. KK Michael Holcomb
Dmitry vinaigrette and Cameron Ellis
enterprises for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see soon continuing
the coverage of the Magnus Invitational
until it ends so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day